time now for morning rounds are look at
the medical news of the week beginning
with the latest news about the
mosquito-borne Zika virus as the weather
gets warmer mosquitoes become more
active and this week the CDC released a
report analyzing statistics and Zika
pregnancy within the United States in
part the report found that last year
about one in ten pregnant women with
Zika had a fetus or baby with birth
defects and that 44 states reported
cases of pregnant women with evidence of
Zika the CDC noted that most of these
cases were travel associated CBS News
chief medical correspondent dr. Jon
LaPook and CBS News contributor dr. Tara
narula are here to discuss all right dr.
LaPook of the 1300 women in this study
how many of them displayed symptoms
during pregnancy well they looked at the
972 who actually had the completed
pregnancy and of those only thirty-six
percent so a little over a third had
symptoms we know that you don't have to
have symptoms and one of the interesting
questions here was we were wondering if
you get infected with Zika during
pregnancy are you more likely to have a
baby with a defect if you have symptoms
than if you don't have symptoms and it
turns out that birth defects were about
equally of equal proportion whether you
had symptoms or not did it matter Tara
at what point in the pregnancy the women
got infected there's so much but we
still have to learn about Zika and in
particular at what point during the
pregnancy might a woman be at highest
risk if she gets infected and in this
report they did in fact find that in the
first trimester women seem to be at the
highest risk so women who were pregnant
and had lab confirmed Zika in the first
trimester at a fifteen percent chance of
having a child infant or baby with a
birth defect and that kind of goes along
with another study out of Columbia that
also showed that women who got infected
in the first trimester or in this early
second trimester seemed to be at the
highest risk again the CDC is telling
everyone all pregnant women that you
have to pay attention as well throughout
the pregnancy not just the first
trimester that there is risk throughout
the entire pregnancy take precautions in
terms of travel mosquito protection and
sexual protection so precautions should
be broad here right 44 states yes that's
but most of the states in the United
States what is that practically means
practice and people get confused about
this so there's a travel associated
infection that means you picked it up
somewhere else you say South America
someplace you brought it back to
wherever you were whatever that state
was the United States it doesn't mean
that there's local mosquitoes in that
state who are infected but remember a
little primer again this is the first
mosquito-borne illness ever to cause a
birth defect and it's the first
mosquito-borne illness that we know
that's also sex sexually transmitted so
you have the double whammy there so it's
not just travel the person can come up
and have sexual relations with a person
a pregnant person somewhere else where
the where there aren't local mosquitoes
that have Zika and then you could get
infection that way and so the bottom
line here is people who are pregnant
women who are pregnant have to really
have a high level of being aware is
there any possibility of being infected
and if that's true you really have to be
very closely followed I read every
single ahead line up also I can you know
because people ask me this all the time
Google cd2 a search for a cbc space Zika
space name of the place you want to
travel to see if there's any local
infection em or CDC space Zika space
whatever it is you're looking for the
CDC is constantly updating this it's
really important because it's changes
alright our next topic dietary
supplements and heart health a new study
published in the american medical
associations cardiology journal looked
at over 5,000 New Zealanders with an
average age of 65 some participants were
given a monthly high dose of vitamin D
the others got a placebo they were
followed for an average of just over
three years researchers wanted to see if
the vitamin D supplement helped prevent
cardiovascular disease to her what did
they find so there's been a lot of
questions around the relationship
between vitamin D and cardiovascular
house since the 1980s when they started
to make observations that people with
low vitamin D seemed to be an increased
risk of cardiovascular disease but the
question really has been to
supplementation actually help and in
this study when they looked at the
groups who got the vitamin D and those
who didn't both groups had about the
same risk twelve percent of developing
cardiovascular disease down the line the
vitamin D group was able to increase
their vitamin D levels but again it
seemed like in this study with monthly
high dose supplementation
there really was no benefit and the
authors are quick to point out though we
don't know what would happen with
different doses with different
frequencies so daily or weekly
supplementation or longer follow ups
there's still a lot of unanswered
questions how popular is vitamin D and
vitamin D supplements in the US well
with supplements in general are about
half of the population takes about 1 30
so you know a lot of people take it
there's a lot of data about this really
hard to show that the supplements really
do help they're still going they're
doing research steve nison from the
Cleveland Clinic emailed me and told me
that he's doing a big study 13,000
people looking at omega 3 fatty acids to
see if it has a role in people with high
triglycerides and low HDL low good
cholesterol but right now he said I'm
not he said I'm not surprised by this
study that I never did drink the
kool-aid kool-aid being vitamin D that's
what he said Tara's a cardiologist do a
lot of your patients ask about
supplements for heart health they do and
they ask about fish oil and things like
that but I think what's more important
is that what people don't tell and
whether they don't tell because they're
afraid that their doctor will say don't
take it or they don't think it's
important but it is important because a
lot of these supplements there really is
no proven benefit to them for most
healthy Americans things like multi
vitamins and antioxidants and for other
things like herbals you know these are
really a class that is unregulated they
don't have to prove safety efficacy or
quality before they get out of the
market they can be mislabeled they can
be contaminated they can have stimulants
in them and they can interact with a
patient's regular prescription drug so
just because it's natural doesn't mean
it's safe talk to your doctor about what
you're on okay with that doctors Jon
LaPook and Tara narula great to see you
thanks for your time